foreign
good morning Michael
what's happening seed oils
you know I'm a pop culture Maven I'm
extraordinarily hip but there is a trend
that I do not understand
this is a trend I've discussed with
friends of mine who are more attuned to
what's going on these days with the
young people they have failed to explain
it to me the trend is a s m r
I've always been more of an spqr kind of
guy I've tried to get it I said ASMR
it's when you just hear sounds really
intimately and loudly in your ear right
say yes
it says is that is that just a porn
thing I say well no well but I so I just
don't know I just don't get it okay and
that's why my producer Ben Davies has
picked all manner of ASMR videos for me
to appreciate this new genre
let's go
oh this is
this is so much weirder than I expected
it to be
oh man that's
that's
really unpleasant which is surprising I
expected it to be very pleasant because
so many people are doing this but it's I
don't like that I don't want like I
don't want to hear someone's saliva
sloshing between their lips and their
teeth their lips the teeth the tip of
the tongue I don't like that at all and
then the weird this thing the tapping
thing I don't like that and I just don't
get it I would get it more if it were
arousing and say well there's all sorts
of weird porn but this is just one of
them but it's not arousing it's not
interesting I'm not learning anything
it's not comforting it's kind of weird
and gross and then there it clearly is
some kind of a pornographic aspect to it
because what the woman had written down
was ILY I love you so it's you're
clearly supposed to feel some stirring
of something for the woman but I don't I
don't I feel nothing but revulsion
disgusting let's keep going
garlic and mayo
ah I hate it
oh that is so disgusting
I can't do it it's so oh it's so
that is that is what I asked Elisa but I
asked sweet little Elise about this I
said what is ASMR and she described food
videos and she said you know you're the
crunch of the bread or like someone
chewing that sounds horrible I hate it
when someone's chewing next to me I want
to punch him in the face are you telling
me someone would choose to listen to
that in earphones and high def sound I
said no it's not quite it's like the
crunch well that's totally gross all
right let's try it again
it's just more chewing ah
hot Cheeto girl ASMR does the hot refer
to the Cheetos or to the girl
I can't overstate how much I hate this
I didn't expect to I thought to just I
would just be not interested in it or
wouldn't move me but I actively hate it
I hate it I can't
I don't want to cut it short because I
want it so gross I can't I can't it's
disgusting
so like one time I remember I was in
college and a buddy of mine who was a
roommate of mine also he comes in and I
just gotten a big block of chocolate I
said oh hey man here you want some
chocolate it's like oh yeah sure if I
give him a piece of chocolate he sits
next to me on my bed and just right next
to my ear
and I almost rang his Little Neck
why did I give you that chocolate
what
I can't do it I cannot believe how
intense a visceral reaction I'm having
against I can't I'm gonna hold it I can
still hear it a little bit from here
that sucks
it's so troubling this is obviously a
porn thing right like look at her dead
eyes and it's so grotesque this is for
people
who have already watched
all the porn on the Internet they've
seen all the naked people of both sexes
they've seen all like five things that
you can do and they're so now they're so
desensitized that they watch some
dead-eyed leather clad lady chomping
down on crab legs my stomach is churning
listening to it okay is that it please
good morning Michael in today's news you
are smart you are appreciated you don't
need to go to the gym ever you aren't
based and totally right about seed oils
people often wonder how they could get
hair that looks manly and sophisticated
like yours the answer is Jeremy's razor
hair and body product this has been
Georgia Howe with daily wire
all right I'm kind of changing my
opinion on ASMR actually yep
also Georgia's got a great voice that is
what ASMR I was told does I was told
ASMR is really comforting and pleasant
and George's voice has it's very
soothing it's very hello hi hi there I'm
you're great man but
looking at some woman eating Crustaceans
and listening to the saliva saliva that
bothers me about his
speaking of weird stuff on the internet
you probably don't want companies and
the government all sorts of people
looking at the stuff that you're
watching hopefully it's not this stuff
but even if you're reading the daily
wire okay if you're reading things that
are politically not looked kindly upon
by our regime then you want to make sure
you keep your data to yourself that's
why you got to check out expressvpn
companies or not just selling products
anymore they're selling you this is how
tech companies enrich themselves by
taking your personal data they grab your
web history email metadata video
searches they create a detailed profile
on you and they sell that off to the
highest bidder when you go online
without a VPN internet service providers
see every website you visit they legally
sell this information without your
consent to add companies and Tech Giants
who then use it to Target you when you
use expressvpn your identity is
anonymized by a secure VPN server so
isps cannot see your online activity
your data are encrypted for maximum
protection I love it I love expressvpn
it's so easy that even I can use it I'm
a total Luddite expressvpn you download
the app you click button you're totally
protected on your phone on your tablet
on your laptop stop laying strangers
invade your online privacy protect
yourself at expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show use my link expressvpn.com
Michael Knowles show to get three extra
months for free
expresvpn.com
michaelenoll's show please tell me this
is almost over
I think we'll convert you
no
can you please just pause this for a
second
or if it were just her voice it was just
her Whispering I'd think well this is
kind of weird but it's not unpleasant
and it's just a nice voice that's fine
but why do I have to hear all this
fingernails scratching on some plastic
cup
no I don't I prefer that to some Maniac
chomping down on a crustacean for
mayonnaise or something the other thing
that's distressing about this is that's
a good looking young woman she could
have a good normal life she doesn't need
to be making weird
pseudosultry sound videos for depraved
people who have been desensitized to
everything on Earth
she could just like go live a normal
life and have a husband and a family and
don't ah it's kind of how I feel about
porn I don't know who I feel worse for
the people consuming or the people
producing it number one if we start
making
number two
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
so far listen here Jack Corn Pop had us
hairy legs what's happening pay them
more
Joe Biden is so old and out of touch
that he's actually the youngest hippest
politician in America it's it's just
horseshoe Theory you know when you go so
far left you become right and when you
go so far right you become left Joe
Biden has gone so out of touch he's
become a 19 year old e-girl making
videos of her whispering and tapping her
fingernails okay is this the last one
please
okay
the hell is wrong with people
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a
foreign
begging you this is a message to all
people people out there watching this
video people who made those videos and
the people who search for and watch
those videos I am imploring you please
be normal please just just do this one
thing for me just please try to just be
normal
if you are in any way titillated
by an Asian woman biting down on a
sloppy slippery honeycomb and then
guzzling reams of Honey out of a bottle
if that piques your interest stop
whatever you're doing
and just do the opposite
yuck
[Music]